welcome to lecture 17
this lecture talks about state dependent
preferences projection
and attribution paths
the plan for today is to talk about
preference changes so
we're going to look at different
circumstances in which people's
preferences
predictably uh and sometimes
unpredictably change over time
that is to say sometimes people are
hungry tired or in pain
and their preferences for certain
outcomes may be
determined by that underlying state of
like hunger for example
now it's pretty clear that people's
preferences change according to those
states
as in like when somebody is hungry they
want different things they want to eat
different kinds of things that when
they're not hungry and so on
um but people nevertheless have trouble
predicting
their preference changes that is to say
if somebody is hungry they may have a
hard time predicting
how it feels when they're not hungry and
vice versa
so uh notice that this lecture is a sort
of a continuation or natural
continuation of our lectures on beliefs
from before so before we looked at
people
trying to learn about unknown
information around them and we looked at
various deviations why people are not
able to learn
now we're going to look at people trying
to learn or
failing to learn at times about their
own preferences
and an important particular case here is
what's called production bias
which is people's lack or for
inadequate ability to predict their own
preferences
in particular for different states of
the world in the future i'm going to be
more specific about that
but mostly we're going to talk about
projection bias in the paper by
lowenstein at all which is in the
readings
we're going to talk very um briefly
about attribution bias and that's going
to be covered in
recitation
okay so although not typically
emphasized in economics the simple and
obvious fact is that our preferences
change over time there's various ways in
which
our preferences change one is short-term
temporary fluctuations and you can call
them sort of
state dependent preferences you can call
all of what we're going to talk about
state dependent preferences
um here is the state is like a short run
physiological or psychological state for
example
hunger pain or the like or
a psychological state such as mood
i'm going to talk about all of these in
more detail
second there are long run systematic
changes
this could be due to own choices such as
addiction
so like if somebody has been drinking
alcohol for the last 10 years
their utility from drinking alcohol or
not drinking alcohol is quite different
from somebody
who has not been drinking um ever same
is true for smoking
and the like or it could be independent
of one's choices for example
aging so predictably people's
preferences change over time when
they're 20 or
years old versus when they're 80 years
old
notice that for addiction there's also
some short run
temporary fluctuation such as when
people have just
smoked a cigarette versus not their
preferences for an additional cigarette
might be quite different
but then there's also long-run
systematic changes which is like
if somebody has been smoking a lot
during the last you know 10 years versus
not so this smoking or addiction in
particular
has both short-term and long-term uh
temporary and systematic changes
in people's preferences and then there's
adaptation to changes
which happens often for big changes such
as standard of living or small changes
such as smug ownership
what's an example here for example if
people win the lottery they become
happier
um they become actually a lot happier um
very quickly
but then that sort of reverts back to
like their the previous standard over
time
people a lottery one receiving like a
few years later clearly are happier than
people who have not won the lottery but
their uh increase in happiness
uh decreases um over time okay so so
these are three different types of
sets of preference changes we're going
to mostly focus in the lecture today
on number one short term temporary
fluctuation
now what i'm going to what am i talking
about here so one
example here is hunger now
studying hunger is difficult in
experiments because
it's unethical to starve people you
could of course find hungry people and
give them food
that's in some sense what was done once
in what's called in the minnesota
starvation experiment
this is an experiment that was motivated
by the fact that there was lots of
soldiers in the second world war in the
us and europe
from the us and europe and in many other
places
and these soldiers had been starved from
the war for a long time and they came
back from the war to
back to the u.s and one simple question
was as well when you when you have
people who have been starved
um have not eaten um for a long time or
very little for a long time how do you
best reintegrate them
into a society or like how do you best
sort of
feed them do you feed them very quickly
like a lot or do you sort of gradually
increase their food take
over time so then the army did some
experiments with healthy volunteers
such as this guy here on the left and
in people were starved literally starved
by
getting very little food on for a while
such that you know after a few weeks the
guy would look like this
and then the army would look at people's
behavior over time
they were mostly interested in like once
you have somebody was not eaten for
quite a while once you give them more
food what's happening to their behavior
and what's
you know the best way of doing that um
coincidentally they also recorded what
what's happening in the first part of
the experiment when people were starved
to start with and so you know as
expected people get
extremely focused on food when they
don't eat for a while they really get
really really interested in learning
about what's going on with food and
when they get next food and so on but as
it happens it seems to me that their
preferences
also change um in various other ways in
particular see people seem to lose
interest and lots of other activities
it's reported
decreased alertness lack of self-control
general apathy people are just sort of
like
almost like a different person when they
are almost starved compared to like when
they have eaten
um a lot here are some testimonies
from from these soldiers uh one of them
is the acquisition of
food-related items was a reasonable
extension of their heightened interest
in food so as we expect people get
really interested in food
much less reasonable was the buying of
old books unnecessary secondhand clothes
knickknacks and other junk often after
making such purchases
which could be only afforded only with
sacrifice the men would be puzzled as to
why they had bought such more or less
useless articles
so that's essentially sort of saying
that people got really interested in
certain purchases
their preferences towards those kinds of
purchases seems to have changed
they seem to have also some preference
reversal they seem to want to buy
certain things and then wonder
afterwards
afterwards why they did so um which all
seems to be the consequence of being
really really hungry
then came the day when i lost my will to
activity
i no longer care to do anything that
required energy and days began to drag
it seems to be in some ways like a like
a direct effect of like having a little
caloric intake
but really um people's preferences
towards physical or any other activity
seems to have changed quite a bit due to
hunger
um and another one here's uh there's
nothing
that can uh hold my interest for long i
wait for
meal time so this is your people's
attention seems to really be
uh lowered quite a bit and to the extent
that we think attention
affects people's preferences in decision
making in various ways
again hunger seems to have this effect
on people's home choices
now what's a more sort of like real
world example
for for you guys well that's shopping on
an empty stomach
it's sort of a classic study by this
ignis but in canoes from 1969 but
there's sort of other evidence
later and the folk wisdom is that
shopping on an empty stomach leads
people to buy more
and perhaps also on more junk food
now how do you study this well you can
think about different ways in which you
might do that
you could sort of induce people directly
to eat when they're hungry versus not
um you know uh uh there's various other
ways in which you could think about like
setting up experiments
now one very simple ways in which one um
i can study this issue is by just
randomly giving
a sample of individuals entering a
supermarket a candy bar
could be a candy bar it could be also
some power bar is there some other food
and so now essentially what you doing is
you take a bunch of people who go
shopping and uh they might be some of
them might be hungry and some might not
be but then the
ones that are hungry in particular when
they eat like a candy bar or any other
food
they might they become less hungry and
so then we have a treatment condition
that's less hungry and a control
condition was not giving any
food who is like more hungry and so then
um that allows essentially to look at
like um
um uh variation in like whether people
are currently hungry um while shopping
another thing one could do is one could
vary the timing of the last meal before
shopping there you worry a little bit
like if that's not experimentally
induced that
the people who like go shopping right
after having a meal versus not might be
quite different than there is
other ways but you could in principle
also like experimentally induce
that and then you know you can look at
like monitor how how much and what kind
of food people buy
so hungry people tend to buy more so
they they just you buy more food
they also more telling they buy more
junk food
so their preferences really seem to be
uh different to be clear people
tend to buy more and not just sort of
like say i'm going to buy like now
i'm a power bar or like example a banana
because i'm really hungry i'm going to
buy it right after
the store but they buy significantly
more more than can be explained by just
filling your immediate hunger
and in particular they also seem to
change the type of food that they buy
in particular in this case here more
junk food
kind of what this thing looks like the
left guy is
uh full he he buys lots of lettuce diet
water and so on the guy on the right
um is hungry he buys all sorts of things
a lot more as you can see um and a lot
of also like
unhealthy food including tortilla chips
cheese sugar water
um and so on uh so you know next time
you go shopping you should
introspect and see what your preferences
towards what you buy
have been affected now another thing you
can think about is
uh that affects your preferences
underlying state
is your sleep when you're tired the
whole world seems different in various
ways
um you know one example could you think
about it's like
self-control sleep deprivation is
associated with lack of self-control
um there's sort of this literature old
literature that says self-control is a
muscle that replenishes overnight
there's some issues with this um uh with
this literature
there's some experiments that might not
necessarily um
uh replicate uh uh uh but the idea that
um
lack of self-control um uh might be a
consequence of
lack of sleep uh seems very plausible um
in various ways uh uh notice that nicole
should also be causality in the other
direction lack of self-control may also
be a cause of
poor sleep now uh there's some evidence
that sleep affects
proposed preferences um when people are
sleep deprived
um they tend to gain weight uh tired
people engage more in what's called
cyber loafing you serve more in the
internet
um there's also some evidence that sleep
might or lack of sleep might affect
ethical behavior people cheat more
when they're tired um and we have some
evidence in our experiment
in india which i'm going to show you in
a little bit uh
at the end of the semester that maps
increase savings and seem to reduce
people's
um present by us so really this is
some evidence of sleep affecting
people's time preferences
uh another uh example is badger adolent
and addiction
um this is a very small study with only
like 13 subjects
you know you might sort of take all of
what's in there with a little bit of
grain of salt
um but you know i think the the
underlying message and the findings
are are correct so what did bachelor
doll do
they elicited people's willingness to
pay for a second dose of the heroine
substitute bop
these are heroin addicts that are
recovering and they tend to have um
often cravings and dop essentially helps
people
not to relapse and not to take heroin
again
and so they get at regular intervals
they get bop doses
now it would be sort of unethical to
withhold people
on these doses but what the experiment
was doing
and it's still sort of ethically
ethically perhaps tricky but what they
were asking for is people's willingness
to pay for a second dose of heroin
of the ap the heroin substitute so all
individuals in the experiments
regularly regularly receive their single
dose of bop
and um and then there's also like
an additional dose they could get and
then there was some variation in the
experiment
what was the duration there was
variation in the state of deprivation
so um people were either asking all the
questions about
our willingness to pay for a second dose
of vop
right everybody always got the first
those but then uh there was some
variation in timing for some people um
uh the more deprived condition
people ask about their willingness to
pay for a second dose two hours before
the scheduled first those
and the last deprived people were asked
like right after the scheduled first
stones
again everybody's getting a first close
and we're asking about willingness to
pay for a second dose otus
some people ask about this two hours
before the scheduled first dose when
they're really sort of deprived and
craving when they really want their
first dose
and others are asked when they're less
deprived
right after the scheduled first stops
notice that the second dose is always
held constant
so everybody always gets the first dose
and the second dose is held constant in
the future at least in those kinds of
questions
so really the willingness to pay should
not depend on your current state
right in the future you're going to get
a second dose which is once you have
already gotten the first dose
so like whether you i ask you like two
hours before or right after your
schedule goes through
will have more effect on your
willingness to pay in the future because
that's gonna
that experience is held fixed and you
always get the first bills
now they also asked varied in addition
the timing of a potential second dose so
sometimes the second dose was later on
the same day and sometimes the second
dose was
during the next week
now what do badger badger adele find
they find that people's willingness to
pay
very systematically with the state and
the deadline
what's the state here the state is a
state of deprivation whether people are
more deprived or less deprived
and then the timing is essentially
either about today versus
next week now the median willingness to
pay
for the second dose later today is fifty
dollars in the satiated state and
seventy five dollars in the deprived
state
now we're gonna um get back to this how
we think about this how we can explain
this
but basically the way that we explain
this is that in the deprived state
people's willingness to pay um is higher
um because they really really want like
a first dose so people's willingness to
pay for the first dose
is high in the price state and it's
lower in the satiated state because i
already have the
or the sorry people's willingness to pay
for any additional dose
is high in the deprived state because
they haven't even gotten the first those
and it's lower on in the associated
state but what people seem to be doing
now they seem to have like a hard time
imagining their utility in the future
that is to say in the future both people
will be satiated
so what's happening here is that people
when people are in the deprived state
they really really want bup
and they're willing to pay more than
when
in the satiated state again for the
second dose of the future
now there's also some evidence of
willingness to pay for the
second dose next week and again people's
willingness to pay
and so the previous one was later today
uh now it's for the next week
people's willingness to pay and the
deprived state is uh
sixty dollars in the satiated state
that's thirty five dollars
so um again people's willingness to pay
us
higher in the deprived state that is to
say when in
the private state really really really
people want to be a p
and they cannot really imagine that in
the next week um
people's uh when they're satiated there
they will actually
want bop um less to be clear
in both the um uh the first one
the late those is later today and when
it doses next week
uh it'll always be the case that people
have already received the first date
those and then the question is always
about what's your willingness to pay to
receive a second dose
so when they're in the future they will
always be satiated
but people in the deprived states seem
to be reacting or seem to be behaving as
if
in the future they would also be in the
deprived state but of course people will
be in the satiated state
so people seem to overestimate uh when
they're under the private set how much
they
would like the second dose in the
satiated state
in the future now here's another example
by
shelling and shelling is a beautiful
writer
in economics he's one of the best
writers that economics has granted
there's lots of bad writing in economics
but if you want to write some
read some beautiful writing
by an economist shelling has a bunch of
different
books that are really nice to read and
essays that are really beautiful
now in his paper 1984
um he talks briefly about a
controversial question which is the use
of anesthesia during childbirth
and why is that controversial well
anesthesia is reducing
the mother's pain during during
childbirth
but there's the potential for some side
effects there's also the potential that
people
uh experience is is different and
for both of those reasons some people
argue that
anesthesia is not warranted and
decide not to do that now in many cases
people's preferences
change predictably over time first
ex-ante before the woman gives
birth many women prefer not to use
anesthesia
once there are in excruciating pain they
request
they request anesthesia from their
doctor
and then if they actually get the
anesthesia from the doctor
exposed after um the child is born
they regret their choice they say i wish
i hadn't gotten anesthesia
now that pattern holds even for women
who have given birth before
and it causes or it leads to a bunch of
ethical dilemmas and legal issues
for example to which patient is a
physician obligated the one asking for
anesthesia or the one who asked that
that it be what would help right the
person told the doctor like i really
really do not want any anesthesia
even if i ask you later please do not
give me anesthesia
but then of course the person then yells
at the doctor and says i really really
want anesthesia give me anesthesia right
now
and so there's essentially different
there's preference reversals people seem
to want
different things at different points in
time and
uh the doctor no you know can only make
one of these two people
happy and so no matter what the doctor
does either if the person gets and just
gives the person anesthesia
then person number two in my list here
above is going to be happy but person
number one
person number three are unhappy or the
person withholds anesthesia and then
person number two is unhappy so either
way the doctor cannot satisfy
uh these different selves over time
now can the physician enter a contract
with the patient ex-ante before
is it is it possible to have a legally
binding contract here when he says like
you know
he or she says i'm not going to give any
anesthesia and you told me so
um do we want policies that such
contracts
make such contracts possible is that an
is that a desirable thing to do is it a
legally
required thing to do potentially or
possible to require this legally
i'm not sure but the point here really
is that
um there is um uh some misprediction
going on here right ex-ante the the
person says well
if i'm in pain i will be fine i'm not
gonna need anesthesia
but then of course when the person is
actually in pain the person wants
anesthesia so essentially
people seem to mispredict their
preferences
when they're in pain and that leads to
all sorts of trouble here i really
recommend you read the
paper by shelling that's on the course
website if you want to sort of think
about this a little bit more
now so far um we talked about that
preferences
change predictably due to changes in
underlying states
now what are those those states it could
be like pain hunger
sleep and so on now there's additional
status factors that people make
systematic mistakes at predicting
preference changes
right so people not only is it that your
preferences are different when you're
tired versus
not but people are also systematically
mispredicting that preference change
now what is production production bias
to be clear it's the fact that people
under
appreciate changes in their preferences
projecting their current preferences
onto future preferences
so production bias to be clear is not
just some random misprediction
but a misprediction with a systematic
direction
so people seem to understand the
direction of preference change but not
the magnitude
that is to say when people are hungry
and think about like
how it's gonna feel when they're not
hungry anymore they kind of understand
that eventually they will not be hungry
and that maybe you know
suppose you're really hungry and really
want potato chips you sort of understand
that you don't really want that many
potato chips um
when you're full nevertheless when
people are hungry they buy like 10 bags
of potato chips as if they were like
hungry at least for like half of their
life even though they're just you know
they're going to be hungry for the next
hour or two because then they're going
to go home and go eat um
and so on so people seem to understand
the direction of people's preferences
but not
the magnitude now
um
the under appreciation of the effects of
hunger and preferences
is you know perhaps not the most
economically important
um uh part of of
production buyers be the most important
application but there's two reasons to
consider this evidence
but one it's perhaps the clearest
evidence of production bias
second people had lots of experience
with changes in
their levels of hunger so any
misprediction isn't due to the lack of
opportunity to learn really
one should have probably learned uh this
over time
for some other instances where you know
um this is only for example if you have
lots of physical pain or for childbirth
for example
you might say well um uh you know that
seems to be like uh
sometimes even one-in-a-lifetime
experience where like people really um
it's sort of understandable that people
mispredict uh
uh their preferences when they be an
excitement they are in excruciating pain
um but that's sort of understandable
because you haven't experienced it
before
and even you know for somebody a mother
who has given
birth to a child before that mother
might sort of just not
misremember to some degree but when it
comes to hunger
people have been hungry so many times
and full and so on so like really you
have lots and lots of opportunities to
learn
what your preferences are when you're
hungry um versus not so really it
shouldn't be about a lack of opportunity
to learn now people buy more on an empty
stomach that can be interpreted as a
minus
beneficial production bias hungry people
act as if their future taste for food
will reflect their current hunger at
least to some
degree or more so than it actually does
but it's not completely clean evidence
of production bias because there could
be always other things going on for
example if you're really hungry
um you might focus uh some things might
be more salient to you and you know
there you might
sort of buy certain things more because
um you pay more attention for example to
potato chips and really sort of learn
how
exciting potato chips are and so on but
um let's just go with hunger um
for now there's lots of other evidence
of production bias
in addition to to the hunger example
now remember the paper on that we
discussed on food choices by
wheat and van loyvan this is the paper
where office workers are asked to choose
between a healthy snack and an
unhealthy snack now so far we have
looked at
um this as a piece of evidence for
present bias we were looking at when
people are choosing for the present
right now versus when they choose for
the future
do people make more uh
unhealthy choices when they choose for
the present that is to say this
nice fact that we found was that when
people are
choosing snacks for the future they were
um
quite likely to choose healthy snacks
you know you choose salad for the future
um
as your um snack in the afternoon and
when then and you ask again like right
now or today what would you like
people to seem to switch their
preferences towards
unhealthy snacks that rather have like
um chocolates
and so we interpreted that at the time
as evidence of
present bias and surely it seems like
that is evidence of present bias
now in addition now we're going to
consider variation in the timing of
those choices
so some people were asked when they were
hungry late in the afternoon
others were asked when they were
satiated or arguably satiated
immediately after lunch and then the
snacks were to be received in one week
so that's
how constant timing otherwise the timing
is held constant
so we're always going to look at choices
for snacks to be received in one week
some of the uh in some of the cases the
snacks were uh to be received when
people were hungry or
likely hungry late in the afternoon in
some other cases
um the snacks were received when people
were satiated
immediately after lunch okay so there's
like four cases here
there's the timing of choice either
people ask where they're hungry versus
not
um and then the timing of the receipt of
the snack which is when they were hungry
versus not the question now is are
hungry people now good or bad at
predicting
their preferences when they're satiated
and or satiated people
are good or bad when they're um
predicting their preferences
when they're hungry sort of in the
different state
okay so we're going to interpret here um
the
so here's a table i'm from reading van
loyden table number one
uh it's a bit of a sort of confusing
table um
for no good reason uh let me just walk
you very
quickly through that table so the rows
are
the current hunger and the columns are
future hunger
so the first row is when people were
asked when they were hungry
so this is like late in the afternoon
the second row is people were asked when
they were satiated that's like
um right after lunch and then the
columns are
um again remember all of the choices are
for
next week so the first column is choices
for when people were um
hungry that's late in the afternoon and
the second column is when people were
satiated that's right after lunch
remember again
all choices are for next weeks or
for one week in the future now
we can interpret now the main diagonal
of this table
as reflecting people's true preferences
that is to say
here's no projection bias here people
are asked when hungry about
to predict what they wanted or to say
what they wanted
in the future when they were likely
going to be hungry as well
that is to say 78 of people are um
choosing an unhealthy snack for the
future
um when they're hungry so that's in the
late afternoon
for the future case when they're in the
late afternoon
in contrast only 26 percent of people
choose
um uh the unhealthy snack when they're
satiated
that is um right after lunch uh for when
the
um uh uh the
snack will be delivered in one week
right after lunch
right so there's here's no production
bias here because essentially this
underlying state hunger is held constant
hungry people uh predict them for when
they're hungry or
asking what they want when they're
hungry 78
of people think they want unhealthy
stuff and um uh
again satiated people 26 of people say
um they want unhealthy stuff so 74 of
people say
they want the healthy snack in contrast
when they're
satiated okay so again that's that's
what's written here late in the
afternoon when people are hungry 78
percent of people choose the unhealthy
snack for the late afternoon when they
will be hungry
immediately after lunch when they're
satiated 26 percent of people
choose the unhealthy snack for
immediately after lunch when they
will be satiated now
then what we see here is um uh uh
the the entries that are off the main
diagonal
those data fit the pattern of projection
bias
now what do i mean by that let's look
first that when people who are hungry
but expect to be satiated that is the
um the the first row here current uh
hunger is hungry that's essentially
people
ask late in the afternoon or think about
this as being lightly hungry
and they ask about like when uh
what do they want when they are
um when they're satiated
that is like right after um lunch
now remember um when people were
satiated
26 of people said they wanted an
unhealthy snack
now when people are hungry 42 of people
say
they want an unhealthy snack so that
fraction is
higher so that is very much consistent
with
projection bias the reason being that
when hungry when people are hungry
um and say what they want for themselves
um in the hungry state
well 78 percent of people say they want
the unhealthy snack
if people did not have any production
bias they really should be saying 26
if you sort of believe that satiated
people know best what they want when
they beat
when they will be satiated instead 42
the higher fraction of people say
they want um an unhealthy snack um or
while when predicting or when when when
i'm answering while they're hungry
for when they would be satiated so
people seem to understand the direction
in which their tastes change as they
become satiated
but they underestimate the magnitude of
this change
similarly people who are currently
satiated but expect to be hungry
underestimate the effect of hunger on
their preferences for unhealthy snacks
remember um satiated people
sorry hungry people um when they when
they want to
when they choose for uh next week when
they will be hungry 78
of people say um they want the unhealthy
snack
now in contrast when they associated 56
of people choose the unhealthy snack so
again that fraction now deviates from
the
fraction when people are are hungry
which is again
consistent with people understand the
direction
in which tastes change as they become
hungry but they underestimate the
magnitude of this change
so satiated people think that when
they're in the future hungry
they will behave um at least a little
bit like
as if they were satiated and hungry
people seem to think that
when they're satiated in the future they
will still behave as if they were
hungry notice that um uh that this
misprediction is
partial so again so both the the 42
is in between the um
the 42 is in between the uh 26 percent
and the um let me see
the 42 is in between the 26 and the 78
percent
and again the 56 percent is between the
26
and the 78 so there's essentially some
partial misprediction
um going on here now
uh let me show you now a number of other
examples of
um projection bias and then i'm gonna
write down a little model that sort of
captures um this intuition
or the iteration that's here so uh uh
one
another example is catalog orders this
is condo nadal
imagine um there's a cold evening it's
really cold outside maybe you were just
outside and so on and then you are
online
shopping notice that in condolence
really it's catalog orders
and not online shopping because online
shopping didn't quite exist
at the time uh but any in any case you
imagine you
buy online a warm uh jacket
and again it's like really cold right
now you really wish you had a warm
jacket
but then when the the
warm jacket arrives it's 30 degrees
warmer um
uh when that happens now um that could
could not be or potentially is a mistake
in particular if it's an unusually um
cold um a day if people have production
bias they might sort of think that well
right now they really need like a warm
jacket and they can't even imagine that
they might not need this warm jacket
anymore
um in a few days from when it actually
arrives from the order
and so the hypothesis is that production
bias leads to an increase in purchases
of
cold water weather items on cold weather
days
and not only that but controlling for
received day temperature the
likelihood of returning a cold weather
object is higher
when the day of ordering was cool so not
only are buying people are buying more
cold weather items on cold weather days
that seems very reasonable because you
know you might just say i always wanted
a jacket anyway it's really cold and i
that just reminds me that i really need
one or for example it's really rainy and
you buy an umbrella because again you
sort of just remember that you really
needed one or maybe if you got it
somewhere and so on but the telling part
here is that the likelihood of returning
the cold
weather item object is higher when the
day of ordering um
was called right and that's very much
consistent with production bias
people on cold weather days act as if
um the future were only full of cold
weather days
and therefore their preferences
would be such that they would always
want cold weather items
or differently people act as if um
their preferences for cold weather items
who really want a warm jacket
would not change even if in the future
there will be warm days
notice that in some of this evidence
what's hard to distinguish
is the the the predicting people's
preference change in the future versus
predicting future
states so if somebody predicted that
it's going to be
cold forever you would act in the exact
same way
as if like you predicted that your
preferences are such that you always
want warm jackets you're always going to
be cooled
now production bias is about the latter
it's about people's preferences
but often it's actually hard to separate
predict
predictions of probabilities of how how
likely it is that it's going to be cold
in the future
from predictions of people's utility
um another example is car purchases on
sunny versus
rainy or cold days imagine it's a nice
sunny day and you go
car shopping as you do it well
why and the the car dela offers your on
audi tt um you know why i guess i never
thought of the audi gt you go for a test
drive
and the wind whips through your air it's
really sunny and great and like having
this this car
during the sunny day is really amazing
so you know you would love to
to buy a car like this why not
imagine in contrast car purchases on an
icy day
imagine your car shopping around the
time of a freak snowstorm you kind of
wanted to have a car
and somehow it's a snowstorm when you go
car shopping
now the car dealer says how about this
grand
uh jeep grand um cherokee you know what
you might say what
why i guess i never thought of the the
jeep grand cherokee why not um
try it you go for a test drive and you
main traction on the black eyes and you
jump the curb with these it's just
amazing now you might just say well i
would love a car
like this now what people seem to then
forgetting in both of these examples is
that it might just happen to be
a really uh bad snow day
on that particular day or it might have
just been like really sunny on that
particular day
and things might change um over time and
people might not
um understand that their preferences for
the audi versus the jeep might change
with the weather over time and that's
exactly what buses
are looking at they're looking at how
does weather
impact auto mobile purchases
and in particular what they look at is
the weather on or
the prediction is that the weather or
the neoclassical prediction is that the
weather
on the day of a car purchase should have
no influence on the type of car
bought so now what blizzard now look at
is do idiosyncratic weather conditions
controlling for time of year
predict car sales and then in particular
also
returns of those cars and they look at
two types of cars in particular
convertibles and then they look at four
wheel drives like the jeep that i just
showed you
and the key part here is that you look
at like idiosyncratic weather
conditions that is to say controlling
for time of the year
suppose it's an unusually warm and
unusually colder icy day
does that predict people's car sales um
our purchases
and particularly also the returns of
those cars
now the the buying patterns are very
much consistent with production bias
people buy more convertibles and good
weather days and
more four-wheel drives on bad weather
days
and then in particular and again that
evidence by itself is not necessarily
production bias it could just be a good
weather day and you kind of always
wanted to buy a really nice car and
therefore you just do it on the good
weather day
but people are also more likely to
return their convertible
if they bought it in a good good weather
day and they're more likely to return
their four-wheel drive
if they bought it on a bad weather day
and that's very much consistent with
evidence of production bias
on a good weather day you think you know
your convertible is going to be amazing
forever
you're going to be love driving and even
if it's going to be raining it's going
to be amazing
but of course if it's raining a
convertible is really not like a car
that you
want to have or it's really cold outside
that's really not a great car to have
similarly um if you have a four-wheel
drive and it's really warm and nice
outside
you'd probably much rather have like a
lighter car and or potentially even like
a convertible
now one important question here is now
in any the
of the behavioral biases that we
discussed is how does the market react
to such behavior
so one tricky part here is that you want
to be kind of careful so
on the one hand you might sort of say
well let's exploit this kind of behavior
and i think that's right you might sort
of get people to purchase stuff that
they don't necessarily
um want and truly that's happening in
some cases
but to the extent that people can just
just return these items
that's actually not necessarily a great
idea particularly if you're if you're a
policy it's car sales person and you
sell people's stuff and then just come
back and you have to deal with them and
they're unhappy
and maybe then at the end of the day to
just return the car and actually don't
buy anything eventually
because they're unhappy that's really
not great for you plus it wastes a lot
of time
and effort on the other hand uh
you know sometimes people might just not
return things and they might just sort
of get stuck with their car
and and just leave it at that and then
it might be a good idea to exploit this
behavior
in particular sort of like on on a good
weather day you might want to try
to sell people convertibles another
thing you could potentially exploit
is essentially people just have higher
willingness to pay
suppose somebody really really wants to
buy a convertible anyway regardless of
the weather
but on a good weather day their
willingness to pay might be higher
and so you might be able to sell them
additional stuff so you might be able to
to sell them maybe a nicer version of
the car
which probably they're not going to
return because you know once they have
it they're just going to keep it
and so you might want to um
you know exploit that if you're on a
company
you might also um or there might also be
some agency issues within the
um the the car car
um sales shop
which is like if the sales person really
wants to um
sell things and is incentivized to sell
things
and that's regardless of the returns
then you might get into situations where
in like sunny days lots of convertibles
are being sold but they're all being
returned
so if you are a company you kind of want
to set the incentives right
then like it's that car salesman gets
only rewarded for stuff that's not
returned because it precisely gets you
like things that
will not make you happy or profitable in
the long run
now there's a another um so as a
customer now how might you take
advantage of production bias
well in in some ways there's an article
here that you can look at that argues
that winter is the best time to buy a
convertible
and so the reason is of course is
convertibles are
are often cheaper in in winter in part
because you know the car sales dealer
might have like
storage costs the like so the
convertibles is actually cheaper or you
know just because people are taking
advantage of
in the summer but they really want
convertibles now you might sell and say
well let's just buy a convertible in the
winter and i think that's in principle
right if you have like the time to wait
until the summer or like a long time
horizon
now you want to be a little bit careful
with exploiting these market conditions
um as a neoclassical
agent uh which was manifested by uh
some of my colleagues who um
shall be named who wanted to buy a
convertible uh sometime in the summer
they were really excited about the
convertible but then they should have
realized that well
winter is actually the time to buy a
convertible because it's going to be
cheaper
so then i decided well let's just wait
until the winter and then buy the
convertible um
then of course but then unfortunately
happen or maybe fortunately and depends
on the perspective
once winter arrived they actually didn't
want a convertible anymore
because you know driving a winter a
convertible in the winter is really not
a lot of fun
so projection bias perhaps um also
kicked in with my colleagues
where they then perhaps should have just
bought the convertible and then
predicted that in the summer they really
wanted it
but instead they didn't buy it because
in winter who wants a convertible um
in the winter so when exploiting
behavioral biases from others you want
to be careful that
you might not be affected or that you
may be affected by it
yourself let me give you one last
example which is this
example by van goghen and loinstein
which is about thirst here
visitors are asked before or after the
gross cardiovascular workouts
people go into the gym to complete a
short survey
and the survey was as follows imagine
that three vacationers in colorado this
past
august embarked on a short six mile hike
as the day were on they realized that
they were complete they were hopelessly
lost
worse because they had packed lightly
for a short hike
they had not carried much in the way of
food or water
and what people were asking about and so
they were essentially given this um
this this story and then um
in the space below please uh they're
asking the
to do the following in the space below
please take the perspective of one of
the three hikers and describe your
situation
how you got into it how you feel now
both physically and mentally
and what what you are um hoping will
happen
and now um what happens or what the
evidence of when logan and laurencing
says is that
thirsty subjects have way more empathy
for
others thirst so when you look at
different outcomes uh
before and after um exercising remember
after exercising is when people were
thirsty
uh third thirst was mentioned
um uh uh before hunger and the essay for
how thirsty people watch more thirst was
unpleasant for hikers was mentioned much
more
hikers would regret not packing water
thirst more unpleasant for the self
oneself would regret more uh uh not
packing water so all of these items that
i sort of like
um first related people when they were
thirsty after exercising were way more
um focused on than than
not so it is as if you like people are
production bias in a sense like people
um
understand much more that the condition
of thirst is really bad
um when they're thirsty compared when
they are not
okay so let me take stock here what
would we discuss so i showed you some
evidence of production bias for many
short run changes and preferences uh uh
and sort of at least for some of them
there's hunger thirst pain sleep
weather addiction there's other evidence
as well as arousal
um anger sadness and so on when people
are in certain states they have trouble
to predict their preferences
when they're not in that state now
one key question that i don't have a
great answer for you is why do people
not
learn people have lots have had lots of
experience with a lot of these changes
in particular when you think about like
sleep or hunger or the like
but even for addiction people just have
smoked a cigarette versus not
that happens all the time so they really
should have learned over time to predict
their preferences
um so the misprediction is really not
due to a lack of opportunity to learn
yet people really seem to believe all
the time that this time is different
over and over again so i think that's
just a very
deep cognitive bias in some ways in the
sense that when people are
affected by certain visceral or other
aspects that affect their preferences
it's really hard to imagine how you
might feel
when that visceral influence
is not at play anymore in the future
in addition to people underestimating
short-run changes and preferences people
also underestimate adaptation to
long-range
so dan gilbert if you're interested has
a
very nice work on a book including a
book called stumbling on happiness
it gives many examples of the
underestimation of adaptation
which which they call immune and neglect
and so
the question here is how does a positive
or or so one example is how does a
positive or negative 10-year decision
affect well-being and so they ask
asking current assistant professors at
you at the university of texas to
forecast
and then they ask like as well former
university of texas assistant professors
to recall
and you know as a current assistant
professor like myself
if you do the forecast if there's a
negative 10-year decision you know
life will be terrible and like how will
we ever i'm
going to live after after uh being
denied a tenure
um and so when you
look at what's actually happening well
people seem to be
professors seem to be relatively
accurate in predicting
the immediate impact of the 10-year
decision but they overestimated the
long-run impact
that is to say in fact immediately after
being denied 10-year people are
maybe you know arguably or
understandably disappointed
and unhappy but over time the long run
effect is much less severe people seem
to adjust to their circumstances
in the medium and long run people's
people are uh
almost as happy as if not uh as happy as
if they are
uh had gotten ten years so there's
actually not much of a long run effect
yet people seem to mispredict the effect
they really seem to think like
in the short run the effect will be
really bad and that bad effect will be
um
last will last forever so people seem to
essentially sort of
understand there's a psychological
immune system to
bad events people recover from negative
shocks quite well
over time but people seem to mispredict
this recovery which again is what's
called immune neglect
there's similar misprediction for other
life events such as
paraplegia or lottery ones for like for
very negative and positive events
people seem to misunderstand that like
again in the short run
there's usually a pretty large decrease
or increase
in people's happiness and life
satisfaction
but people tend to recover from that
quite well over time
but in their prediction people seem to
mispredict
that adjustment people seem to think
that these bad
uh the bad effects on happiness or bad
or good effects and happiness
would persist forever let me now show
you a simple model of production bias by
lawrence d nadel
that formalizes some of the intuitions
that we discussed
so far
[Music]
so suppose true utility of time t
depends on both consumption
ct at time t and the state st at time t
so it's u of c g s t
the state could be anything that affects
utility from consumption
from ranging from the level of hunger or
addiction whether somebody had just
smoked versus not or whether somebody
has just gotten some pop
uh dose or not or past consumption um
et cetera whether somebody is tired and
so on
now the prediction at time t of future
utility
uh uh at time tau larger than t
for consuming c tau and state as tau
is u hat of c tau s tau
and that equals one minus alpha times u
of c c tau s tau plus alpha
times u of c tau s t
now what is this expression well if you
look at the first part
u of c tau s tau that is the
correct future utility at time tau
from consuming c tau and state tau
so if alpha was zero then this term here
would go away
this term is just one so that is
essentially a correct prediction
so there's no production bias the person
has rational expectations about their
future
utility um at uh time tau
uh of utility c tau and in state
as tau now if alpha is not zero
then there's this additional term here
so this is the weighted average of alpha
on a weight for this other term here
which i'm going to talk about a second
and one minus alpha of the correct
utility
of consuming c tau and state as tau now
what is this other term here
well um the person gets see tau
correctly so the consumption is right
but the state is wrong and what state is
the person using to predict their future
utility
well it's using st the current state
so the person is essentially using the
current stage to some degree to predict
their future utility
instead of the future state as tau now
notice that if s t
and s tau is the same then there's no
problem here there's going to be no
misprediction
so it better be the case that the states
as t and s tau
are different for example a hungry
person
would mispredict the utility from not
being hungry
so the utility from not being hungry
would be this part
the person is hungry right now at time t
if s t equals hungry the person would
predict their future utility
even when they're not hungry thinking
that they will always be hungry
in the future so alpha between 0 and 1
is the degree of
production bias
[Music]
so just to give you more detail the
person predicts how she'd feel about
consuming c
tau in the future partially at least by
how she'd feel about consuming it now
that's what the parameter alpha is
measuring
alpha between zero and one could be zero
could be one is the degree of production
bias
so alpha equals zero is correct
understanding of future utility that's
essentially no projection bias that's
rational expectations
alpha equals one is full production bias
that's a person who thinks essentially
their future state
will always be their current state which
of course is not necessarily true
so now the person will optimize
according to our perceived future
preferences
you had of c tau s tau and
i'm going to assume for now as an
exponential discounter that's of course
um you can relax that easily in fact in
some of the problem sets from previous
years and from this year
that will be in fact relaxed now let me
give you a very simple example with
hunger again the problem set
this year and past problem that give you
quite a few
other additional examples that you can
study so suppose there are two states
the state is either hungry or not hungry
h or n
and the consumption c t is over burgers
and money
so u of c gt where ct is the number of
um burgers and money that the person has
uh uh um in state h is five times the
number of burgers
um that the person needs plus the
remaining money that's left that's spent
on other things
the utility of ctn when the person is
not hungry is
one times the number of burgers plus the
money that's left
now what does that imply what it implies
that she's willing to pay five dollars
for a burger when hungry and one dollar
went full how do we how do we know that
well we know that because
um uh in the first case when the person
is hungry
uh each burger gives five utils and each
dollar gives one usual so the exchange
rate between burglars and utils
is five so the person is willing to pay
five dollars
per burger in the second case the
exchange rate between burgers utility
from burgers and utility from dollars is
one
so the person is willing to pay one
dollar for burger
now suppose alpha is three quarters
again remember alpha is the degree of
production bias i'm going to go back to
you
alpha is this parameter here alpha is
the degree of projection bias so the
degree of
misprediction so suppose in our example
here alpha
equals three quarters and
the person is not hungry right now what
is their willingness to pay for a burger
tonight when she'll be hungry
so if the person is not hungry right now
her correct
utility um or willingness to pay for a
burger is one dollar we just
established that already she's full and
uh the correct utility
for willingness to pay for a burger
tonight when she'll be hungry
is five dollars now her production bias
is three quarters
so essentially um uh she puts three
quarters of a weight on her um current
state
and one quarter on the full state well
three quarters times one plus one
quarters times five
or like going essentially three quarters
between a difference of four is
essentially um
uh uh uh three so the person essentially
will think that
um their um uh future willingness to pay
is uh
two dollars um for burger um tonight
or but definitely if you think she um
only wants like um
[Music]
uh her willingness to pay will only be
two dollars um for burger tonight if she
orders for burger tonight and the
burger costs like three or four dollars
she will not be um
willing um to do that now um
just to be very clear so like um the
person only uh essentially
if alpha equals three quarters uh the
person only incorporates
one quarter of the preference change
from being full
versus hungry in the future so that is
to say
um there's a difference between of four
dollars between one dollar and five
dollars
and she only takes into account
one-fourth of that four dollars which is
one dollars
so willingness to pay as one plus one
equals two
you can also write this down here uh
instead of using the formula from the
from the equation from before which
essentially is
three quarters which is the again alpha
times the utility
um using the current state
and one quarter using the current the
correct utility
um which is the future state once you
sort of calculate that
um she will be willing to pay more at
most two dollars for pervert
so potentially she's making a mistake um
now and so again in in the um
in the problem set you will have more
examples and questions uh
that allows you to practice with this
little model
now why should you care about projection
bias i showed you
pretty good evidence of production
production-wise in many settings in the
sense of saying like
uh you know we think production bias
really exists and we think production
bias might be
quite important so it might be relevant
in explaining people's behavior and
those settings
now the consequences in those settings
is relatively unimportant
for example in car purchases of which
people buy like convertibles and then
sort of return their convertibles
you know the loss from that is not
particularly large maybe there's some
like
redistribution across people similarly
the catalog orders people might
purchase too many things and return them
really um
the consequences are not that large and
the actions are often reversible
so why should we then care about
production bias well there's at least
two really important applications i'm
going to talk about for a little bit
that really could matter quite a lot one
is addiction which is people mispredict
the utility
from becoming addicted in the future
second is depression and hope when
people
are depressed they might mispredict how
they feel when they're not depressed
anymore
there's also some some i argue that sort
of marriage and relationships
are um uh quite important the projection
bias might be quite important
particularly people have fights
they might want to get divorced very
quickly they might sort of do
rash of things about getting married
really quickly or try to get
divorced very quickly and in fact there
are some laws that
often prevent that people need to
actually have some cooldown period for
like a few days
where they have to sort of like um um if
one wants to like get married for
example you have to get a license and it
takes a few days and only then you can
get married
perhaps or same is true for divorce at
least in some places
perhaps that's um because
people suffer from production by
sometimes and when they really mad at
somebody or something really bad happens
between them or something really great
happen between them
they might not be able to predict that
their preferences
and their views towards the other person
might change um
over time but let me tell you now a
little bit about addiction and
depression and hope so first addiction
and that's the main application we're
going to discuss
so production bias might be important
for people's initiation when people are
starting to take drugs so here let's
define the relative state as the
person's
level of addiction so how much has the
person uh consumed serious cigarettes in
the last
month or year in an unaddicted state
cigarettes are really not that hard to
resist right if somebody has never
smoked before
cigarettes are really not that
attractive same is true also for alcohol
for example
in an unaddicted so in an addictive
state however it's very hard to resist
cigarettes so if you have smoked a lot
recently you really really would like to
smoke on any given day
now the unaddicted person might sort of
think that
experimenting with cigarettes is fun but
does not want to get addicted for the
rest of her life right it's sort of fun
to do it for a while but really then you
want to stop because being addicted for
the rest of your life is really bad
you might get really bad health health
consequences um for instance
and that might give you some false um if
you sort of have production bias you
might have some
false sense of control if you project
your current
non-addicted preferences into the future
you might think that you can
stop smoking or taking drugs if
necessary
and so then the person might try
cigarettes get addicted and consume
much of her life perhaps she wouldn't do
so if she knew she couldn't quit
right that's essentially to say if
you're not addicted right now you might
predict that
it's going to be always easy to stop
smoking and in fact
right now it is really easy to stop
smoking or resisting
um but the person might mispredict that
this will always
be the case in the future even once she
is addicted
um and once she has smoked a lot um
because for the person for the
non-addicted person it's really hard
to imagine that it might be even hard to
resist
in the future in addition they're
quitting and
quitting and restarting cycles are very
common when it comes to addiction
so addicts often express a desire to
stop using substances permanently
but are unable to follow through that's
not surprising and we kind of like
thought about this before um and
quasi-hyperbolic discounting can
essentially predict that
um as well
um short-term abstention in addition is
common well long-run
long-term abstention is rare so in 2000
for example 41
of smokers stopped for at least one day
um trying to quit
and but only 4.7 percent um successfully
abstained from more than three months
that doesn't really seem like
quasi-hyperbolic discounting so you
wouldn't go through like a pointless
short-term pain
um if you're and then not follow through
if you require a hyperbolic discounter
the reason being if you're in particular
that you know that withdrawal symptoms
tend to be on average strongest
at the start of a quit attempt so
hyperbolic discounter would not sort of
go over this really difficult pain
uh in in the short run
um um if you don't follow through
because that's essentially short run
pain now um and then
three uh recidivism rates especially
high when addicts are exposed to
occasional cues related to past
consumption
so treatment programs in fact advise
recovering addicts to move to new
locations
and to avoid places when previous
consumption
where previous consumption took place so
let's sort of go through these um
one by one and try to see whether we
particularly two and three whether we
can explain
those using projection lines
so now let's define the state as the
strength of cravings at the moment and
suppose this varies randomly or with
exposure to cues
how do you explain the starting um a
quit attempt
well suppose an addict is currently
consuming regularly
she experiences periods of low cravings
when it's easy to resist that's like
when the person has just
smoked uh cravings hello and it's easy
to resist
so then the person might think well
it'll it'll always be easy to resist so
she thinks she it's worth um trying to
quit and starts the quitting attempt
now how do we explain then why how
people abandon the quit attempt
well suppose the addict is currently on
a quit attempt something
triggers strong cravings which might
just be over time you get cravings or
maybe the person might just
be exposed to some cues so then the
person feels it's really hard to resist
the drugs
and in particular she thinks drugs will
always be hard to resist so she because
you know currently she's craving a lot
and you can't even imagine that it might
be
um that the craving might stop over time
so she thinks the quit attempt is
impossible to carry you through and so
she abandons it
so that way production bias can both
explain why the person
starts the quit attempt but also why the
person does not follow through
um now
let's give me a second and then um now
how do we
think about the recidivism well here um
um you know there's not necessarily um
uh production bias needed
but here you know people might mis
underestimate
um how important cues are in affecting
people's
um utility so if it's the case that an
addict for example when the addict walks
by like a liquor store or when the
addict
is uh talking to friends whom they have
been taking drugs in the past and so on
that might really increase people's
marginal utility of
using drugs so they might get really
really strong cravings and it might be
really really hard for them to resist
now if you know that as an addict who
who
is recovering who's not taking any drugs
currently
you should at all costs avoid these cues
because you know
you kind of want to make sure that
you're not exposed to them and
but if you have production bias you
might underestimate
the importance of those cues and
affecting um
your utility or your your cravings and
so you might sort of like walk into a
bar thinking like well i haven't really
been smoking or drinking for a long time
so i'm sure they
will be able to resist but of course
then once you're exposed to these
cues um you will not be able to do so
and that misprediction might really then
cause
um recidivism so again that's to that in
that sense
production bias is also consistent um
with that kind of recidivism
due to cues now um
let me talk very briefly only about
depression
uh and the reason being that we're gonna
talk about mental health in a future
lecture
so depressed individuals have the
tendency to project the depressed
feelings
not only to the future but also um to
the past
and so um in particular um
the past tend to think about um
depression is the
inability to construct the future and in
particular when someone is depressed the
past and future absorbed entirely by the
present
and people can neither remember feeling
better nor imagine that they will feel
better um
in the future so that's to say if the
person is really feeling terrible right
now
they also think you know they always
have been feeling terrible in the past
and they also think that they will
always feel terrible in the future
so then you know life might feel
particularly hopeful as there's no scope
for future improvements and if you think
your life was always that bad
there's really um in some cases people
might think that it's really not much of
a reason
to live and that's of course an
extremely dangerous
and
difficult or consequential potentially
misprediction
because of course depressed people can
get better through therapy and to
through to drugs and so on um
and often there's also remission over
time but if people mispredict that
they might for instance never seek
treatment because they think why would i
ever seek treatment if i'm always
feeling terrible
for the rest of my life anyway i'm going
to get back to that a little bit when
talking about mental health
now
one thing that we have not really talked
about is how to think about these
different biases in particular
what's the difference between projection
bias and naive quarter hyperbolic
discounting
so both naivete and quasi-hyperbolic
discounting and production bias entail a
misprediction
so as an example take a smoker who wants
to quit
the naive quasi-hyperbolic discounter
overestimates their future patience
so that person will sign up for a
commitment contract to stop smoking
and might fail due to the overestimation
of usefulness of commitment devices
right that person thinks you know that
commitment uh the person understands
that she has
some suppose that's a partially naive
person
which we need otherwise the person would
never sign up for a commitment contract
suppose the person is partially naive
the person will sign up for that
commitment
contract thinking that's going to help
them stop smoking
but the person is going to underestimate
how bad their self-control problems are
so then the person might fail because i
think the commitment device is really
really helpful but in fact it's not
strong enough now um for protection bias
the person might underestimate the
influence of altered future states
so the person might also sign up for
commitment contracts to stop smoking
and then might fail due to the due to
the underestimation
of the changes in future cravings that
is to say if you are
currently not craving you might sign up
for a commitment contract
that would help you to continue not
using drugs
and you might um underestimate however
how bad the cravings will be in the
future once you see certain cues or the
like
so again you might choose a commitment
contract that is not strong enough
because you mispredict your future
preferences in this case
not because it's in the future not
because you mispredict your beta like in
case number one
but rather because you mispredict how
strongly future states will affect your
preferences
you can also think about another example
anesthesia during childbirth
you can term uh i get similar sort of
um patterns both naive quarter
hyperbolic discounting and production
bias
might be able to explain uh people's
choices there
in particular both of them would
potentially predict
preference reversals now
how can we tell now projection bias in
ibt regarding beta
apart well the key part here is that
projection bias is a state-dependent
risk prediction
so people are more likely to predict
future temptation to either overeat when
hungry
they're more likely to predict smoking
when you haven't had a cigarette for a
while
so when people are when the state in the
future is different from the current
state people might mispredict
their preferences so now and and
present bias in fact it has nothing to
do with the state essentially just about
like
the future versus the present so now
um what we need what kind of variation
do we need to disentangle
uh the two explanations well you need
variation and timing
and a particular variation in states so
present bias would say it doesn't really
matter what state you're in it doesn't
matter whether you're hungry or not
right now
there's always going to be a
misprediction between the present and
the future
and production bias would very much say
the states are matter it's a
state-dependentness prediction okay so
if you wanted to look at like
people's um uh predictions for the
future
present bias or naivete regarding
present bias would say
it doesn't matter whether you have
smoked or whether you're hungry right
now
for your prediction for the future
projection bias would say
it does matter quite a bit but then
there's a
tricky question is when should you in
fact offer people commitment devices
well you should probably offer people
commitment devices if you want them to
choose correct predict uh uh correct
um if you
if you want people to make correct
choices you probably want to
offer people commitment devices at times
when they're in fact in the same state
so when somebody already has cravings
you want to offer them equipment device
because that person really understands
how it will feel
in the future if instead you offer
somebody a commitment device
when they don't have cravings they might
choose their commitment device which i
guess is good
but then they might fail because they
mispredict um how
strong of a commitment device they might
need in the future
okay so let me then briefly summarize so
so what do we talk about so we talked
about state dependent preferences
so preferences very systematically with
the underlying states for example um
hunger food is tastier when you're
hungry uh going on dates is um
a less enjoyable while being sick
classes are best when we're arrested
um now people know that people's
preferences uh vary with their states
they understand that if you ask like 100
people about like
your preference is different when you're
hungry versus not most people would
probably say you know they want
different types of kinds of food and
they like and maybe hide differently
when they're hungry
however there are
biases in state dependent decision
making in particular both intuition and
psychology
suggest that we fail to appreciate the
extent which our preferences change with
the underlying states
production bias is a specific
psychological error of this type
people overestimate the extent to which
future tastes resemble their current
tastes
and they underestimate the influence
that the state has on their utility
and that can lead to a systematic
misprediction i showed you quite a few
applications in particular addiction and
depression might be the most
consequential applications of projection
bias
now there's one more bias that i told
you i'm going to talk about very briefly
again that's going
to be discussed in detail on recitation
which is called attribution bias
now uh attribution bias in some sense is
very similar but it's backward looking
so while projection bias is the
misprediction of the influence of
future states so when you think about
like the future are you going to be uh
how are you going to enjoy a meal
depending on your hungry versus not or
burgers versus salad
how is your future preferences shaped by
future states attribution bias is
instead
backward looking it's the misprediction
of the influence of past
states so that's to say i want to define
that
briefly when judging the value for good
people are
overly influenced by the state in which
they previously
consumed it now let me give you some
examples and again then you'll talk
about this more in recitation
um people are more likely to return to a
restaurant when first
dried when hungry so if you go to a
restaurant when you're really really
hungry you think the food is like
amazing um well in fact it might just be
that
you're really really hungry so when you
then come back to the restaurant you
might be surprised that in fact it's not
that great
um people are also more likely to
negatively uh rate a movie
um uh when they've seen it while tired
well why is that because
the experience is just not that great
and then you sort of think the movie is
really not that great but really it's
just you were tired
people also less likely to recommend a
zoo to a friend if it rains during the
last visit
well it's just the experience of that
zoo is not that great
of course on some days it rains in some
days it doesn't
so you're not gonna tell usually your
friends only go there when it's
sunny people are saying like this zoo is
just not that much fun
and perhaps more um relevant for you
people are more likely to wreck them or
maybe more likely to recommend a class
um that they took um uh while well
rested
so i was um a few years ago i was
teaching um the 1413 at
at 9 00 am and i got lots of complaints
from students
uh about the class being way too early
and i was telling them or trying to tell
them that you know
the class is really lots of fun you may
or may not be able to appreciate that if
you're really
tired so attribution bias might sort of
make you think that
um might attribute some negative or
positive experience
um to the actual underlying quality of
the issue or the
the good that's being offered as opposed
to as you should
to the underlying state again you're
going to talk more about this in
recitation now what's next
uh remember there's no class on monday
april 20.
on wednesday april 22 we're going to
talk about gender discrimination and
identity
please read heather sarson's paper on
section 1 adjust the introduction
thank you very much
you